hey this is pressed talker and you're
watching mind your decisions everyday a
train passes a train station along a
straight line track and the Train moves
at a constant speed two friends a and B
want to determine how long the train is
lacking proper equipment they devised
the following method they first
synchronize their walking both a and B
walk at the same constant speed and each
step they take is the same length
one day they line up back-to-back at the
train station when the front of the
train reaches them
they both start walking in opposite
directions each person stops exactly as
the back of the train passes by if
person a takes 30 steps and person B
takes 45 steps how long is the train in
terms of steps
I think Pedro for suggesting this
problem can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
let's visualize this problem at the very
beginning a and B are back to back just
as the front of the train is passing the
body they walk in opposite directions
and after 30 steps a stops because the
back the train is passing by a B
continues to walk until the back of the
train passes B and this happens after a
total of 45 steps the question is how
long is the Train
so let's focus on the important
components of this problem we have the
very beginning we then have a moving 30
steps notice that at this point B has
also moved 30 steps because they walk at
the same pace finally B walks another 15
steps until the back of the train passes
B so to solve this problem one way we
can do this is to focus just on B in the
second and third diagrams notice that B
has walked 15 steps between the second
and third diagrams what's interesting is
we know exactly the distance that the
Train has moved at this point why is
that well look at the back of the Train
it's moved 30 steps from the very start
plus 30 steps to where B was in the
second diagram plus the 15 steps to
where B is now as person B moves 15
steps the back of the Train moves 30
plus 30 plus 15 which is a total of 75
steps
thus the train is moving 75 steps for
every 15 steps that B is walking which
is 75 over 15 or 5 times as fast as
either A or B is walking now with this
knowledge we can then go back to the
first and second diagram with person a
now here person a
has moved a total of 30 steps and we're
going to consider how far the front of
the train has moved right now the front
of the Train is off the screen
nevertheless we can figure out the
distance as a moves 30 steps we know
that the Train moves five times as fast
so the front of the Train must have
moved 30 times five which is a hundred
and fifty steps so from the very
beginning we have a hundred and fifty
steps to the front of the Train now
notice it's an extra 30 steps to the
back of the Train so we can add these
numbers up to get the total length of
the Train the Train length is 150 plus
30 which equals 180 steps and without
doing much algebra we figured out the
answer did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video these math videos
which can be watched for free inspire
and build confidence for people around
the world and they already have over a
hundred million views let's share the
beauty of mathematics with your help we
can map the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the news
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle presh
at mind your decisions calm and if you
so choose you can check out my books
which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support